AND RUN THIS SYSTEM IN OUR
SPIRIT ANYTHING LESS THAN THAT
IS AN ACTUAL ATTACK ON DEMOCRACY
.
AND I'M, THINKING SO MUCH GREAT
WITH IS YOUR STATE TONIGHT?
>> WE FEEL STRONGLY ABOUT WHERE
THIS RACE IS HEADING.
WE HAVE BEEN DELETE OBVIOUSLY
SINCE ELECTION NIGHT THAT LEAD
HAS SHRUNK OVER THE LAST FEW
DAYS.
SHE DOES NOT HAVE THE AMOUNT OF
VOTES LEFT TO CATCH AS.
HE WOULD HAVE TO GET JUST BY
OVER 63 PERCENT AND IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE SINCE MOST OF
THE NATIONAL MEDIA IS NOT
COVERING THIS, THE LAS VEGAS
MAIL BALLOTS THE ELECTION DROP
OFF MAIL, THAT MEAL WAS
ABSOLUTELY NOT GOING TO BREAK
LIKE TRADITIONAL MAIL THROUGH
THE USPS.
IF THOSE ARE ELECTION DAY VOTER
AND JUST TO GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE
WE HAD MORE REPUBLICANS DROP OF
ELECTION DAY BALLOTS THAN
DEMOCRATS.
SO AGAIN, AS WE PUT OUT THE MAT
FOR THE WORLD, SHE HAS TO WIN B
OVER 60 PERCENT OF ALL OF THIS.
WE THINK THESE ELECTION DAY
BALLOTS COULD BREAK EVEN, WE
COULD STAND TO LOSE THEM BY 15
DISTRICT 20 POINTS.
JUST SUPER PROUD OF MY TEAM, AN
LOTS OF HARD WORK.
IT HAS BEEN AN INCREDIBLY TOUGH
RACE, BUT WE ARE GOING TO WIN
THIS THING HOPEFULLY.
IT WILL BE AN IMPORTANT RACE FO
THE COUNTRY AND MY GREAT STATE.
>> WE SHOULD KNOW BY NOW, IT'S
BEEN TWO DAYS IN CLARK COUNTY,
NEVADA WHERE MOST OF OUR VIEWER
HAVE BEEN SINCE IT'S ONE OF THE
BIGGEST.
YOU BUILT A REPLICA OF THE
EIFFEL TOWER IN YOUR COUNTY.
EVERYTHING IS AUTOMATED, SO I'M
HONESTLY CONFUSED AS TO WHY THE
CAN'T DO THE THEY CAN'T GIVE US
THE RESULTS OF AN ELECTION IN A
FEW HOURS BRICKEY I BELIEVE YOU
NEED TO GET READY BALLOT
HARVESTING AND DROP BOXES IN
UNIVERSAL MAIL OUT BALLOTING.
FIRST, WE DON'T EVEN HAVE VOTER
ID.
COUNTING AS THEY KEEP POINTING
OUT.
IF FLORIDA CAN DO IT, WITH
3 MILLION PEOPLE IN NEVADA, WE
SHOULD KNOW THE RESULTS OF THE
ELECTION.
PEOPLE ARE MISSING THE HUMAN
TOLL, NEVER MIND THE DEMOCRACY
PIECE WHICH IS OBVIOUS THE MOST
IMPORTANT.
YOU HAVE CAMPAIGNS AND STAFFS
THAT ARE CONTINUING FOR 20 HOURS
.
WHEN IS THE CAMPAIGN OUT OVER?
WHEN YOU GET TO TELL YOUR
SUPPORTERS, THANK YOU FOR
EVERYTHING YOU DID, WE'VE WON.
WHEN DO YOU GET YOUR FAMILY TO
ACTUALLY BREATHE THAT IT IS OVER
?
THIS SYSTEM IS FLAWED.
EVERYONE KNOWS THAT, I THINK
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS JUST
THINK THIS IS AN ASTONISHING
PROCESS VERY TIGHT DON'T THINK
IN CLARK COUNTY, WE DID SO MUCH
TO MAKE SURE THIS WAS A SECURE
ELECTION.
WE HAVE LAWYERS EVERYWHERE, WE
HAD ELECTION OBSERVERS.
ME FEEL CONFIDENT THE VOTES, TH
REGISTRAR ANNOUNCED TODAY THEY
ARE JUST OVER 50,000 MORE MALE
VOTES, THEY TOTAL OF 70,000 TOPS
, SO WE NOTE THAT UNIVERSE
AND WE FEEL COMFORTABLE WITH TH
UNIVERSE, BUT NONETHELESS, WE
NEED TO CHANGE THE SYSTEM.
>> IT'S LIKE A ROMAN SIE